so
many video games so many options
90 of them dragon ball z related
what could we possibly play wait a
second
i know what i'm here for i know exactly
what i'm gonna do i hope you're ready
because you're not going to like this
one bit
you skinny what happened this thing it
looks like someone
barfed all over it i mean i know
jackson's gonna but like
someone beat us to it to scrub
the filth off it's like
it's just never gonna go away it'll
never be clean again
he's here
he's excited he's excited to see you
okay jackson jackson hold on hold on
okay stand still okay remember we were
having a conversation recently
about a really great thing that we
should try to do where are you going
where are you going
we're having a conversation recently
about something that we thought would be
a really great idea
we're doing this
wait hold on show it to the camera
yeah okay so
this week we got a really awesome game
it's one of my favorites
yeah i think you guys are gonna really
like it so uh
right now you know it's just it's just
the greatest
game i've ever played it's
so good
why are we friends i'm a dick sherlock
holmes
are you just sitting there inserting and
uninserting your keycard
stop dry humping the doorknob
why aren't you wearing a shirt
assassin's creed black flag is the
greatest pirate game ever
assassin's creed black flag yeah oh we
gotta download an update maybe it's a
patch to fix the numerous bugs
should we just not even download it no
no we'll see we'll see what exactly they
feel like they fixed
hey sega can you can you just stop oh no
damn it it's always showing my name man
you gotta say xavier likes men
i'm not ready for this this form of
torture
i was never designed to go first we
oh yeah it'll be so scary if no one can
see what the hell is happening just turn
the brightness up we know it's not gonna
matter
what okay fine ah come on
campaign this game keeps showing the
thing yeah campaign
should we do re recruit
recruit solider
the winter solider sorry i can only
describe myself as hardened at the site
of
such brilliance
both ultimate badass that's a
man this game looks like it came out in
2005. look at that
what the [ __ ] what is happening
look look how old this game looks this
came out like two years ago
so i don't have to put subtitles for you
like i'm already close enough
remember that other alien video where
they couldn't hear you so i had to put a
subtitle for every single thing you said
what do you mean just the alien video
it's been every single one
all right recruit yeah fine oh i i
will just do recruit uh
at the pace i go ahead it'll take long
enough any on any difficulty
ah we probably won't even get to the
first enemy in the first thing we'll
just be climbing on
on the walls and shifting into them
i need to be able to hear the quality
story
he's so quality it's like he has one of
those things we saw on that
advertisement on his
i'm not going to put a picture to
correspond with what i'm saying because
i don't want to get in trouble with
youtube
thanks gearbox you've given us so much
we did borderlands that was the one game
that
that gearbox did that's the one game
they can design successfully that's
border
you know what it's basically xavier you
don't even like them i don't even like
borderlands
gearbox is just hitler to you marines
hey look your main character man who
looks like everybody drake
nathan drake yes we're john mcclane
we're every main character for the past
30 years if he's voiced by troy baker
i'm done
i'm captain crow and you're my keys
where are we going
heavy resistance you are the last of
them
lance
he looks so bad is that was that
supposed to be bishop it is bishop
well it's another robot that's exactly
like bishop because you can mass-produce
bishop in a factory
oh so does anyone buy bishop robots as
like sex
dolls you probably did
die no in the future i'm being serious
here
you did what's in there is the writing
at least sort of
okay i got the helmet oh
okay this game looks like halo 1.
it does though
why does this look like it was it's more
like halo 2
it looks like give it some credit
halo 2 the game that came out two years
after halo 1.
it's it was a bit better you know what
just skip the tutorial
we'll figure it out yeah i'm bored okay
you guys remember that really awesome
game oh i can't see my feet oh i can't
you can't even look down how far can you
look down not
far not you you basically can just turn
your head and then your your chin
oh exploding bumps your chest and then
you can't look any further
um hey man so um michael bay
invaded his space station why can you
only walk
so fast
how the hell did this get put out this
game looks so
old remember it's relief trailer
remember that yeah
i can't even not make i can't not make
progress
there's nothing for you to even screw
around with the game is just a tube
here's the start you walk to the end of
the hallway credits
you're done hernandez
ramirez ramirez
get to the drop zone should i conserve
ammo
you just punch all the aliens because
that's a thing you can do
the fact that there is a melee in this
game is disgusting
it hurts you physically okay you know
what i'll give this game one thing the
motion tracker is more accurate than
alien isolations
wait wait wait hold on hold on stop look
back up at that light
no turn look up
what the hell what the [ __ ]
guys that looks so bad
what is what is it's just a mess of
different
shapes floating into each other are you
even gonna
are you even gonna make progress are you
just gonna rub your clock on that guy's
face
man i'm gonna have to bleep a lot of me
talking i turn brightness all the way
down for
for effect wait there hold on go to that
white milk stain
oh it's bishop remember in the scene
where bishop
just splattered all over the place yeah
i never saw
alien 3 because every time i said hey
can i go watch alien 3
every single person threw up and said no
it's like the guy who threw up on the
box of this game and then turned it back
into game stop
and was like here you go and the
gamestop guys were like i can't blame
you
you know what the guy at gamestop
basically just said here you go get out
i asked for this game i said uh do you
have aliens colonial marines
and they like ran over to the shelf got
it off super quick and then handed it to
me
and then just ran behind it at the
counter and was like all right go go
come on come on
leave leave just give us your money and
leave
oh that door opened you oh fire
fine a fire
stop no what are you just
are you just burning yourself to death
no get out of the fire
no like no dad
come on no please what are you doing
this
why are you killing us
you maniac
i won the only way to the only way to
win is not to play
you may part two part one is just you
walking around being a child
so an average game play session yeah
yeah
at least you're actually talking right
like hey tc identified synthetics
hilarious thing
and he just goes yeah yeah yeah really
ain't saying much
no way i'm gonna cut this out plug plug
no i gotta cut this out
i've come up with a strict policy of
never telling anyone to subscribe to me
directly except that time will did it
when i i forced them to
you know part of me is starting to think
that they just took things that were in
this game and then put them in isolation
and said let's make this better
okay can you seriously turn up the
brightness this is no black screen
the horror though man no we're in the
wall
it's just blackness and then red gross
textures
they're in the wall seriously turn it up
so we can see the good textures
okay fine so we can see how good this
game's graphics are
no you know what there's this really
great scene where oh wow
that looks so bad you can see the
individual squares
it looks like pixels in the darkness
wow that's actually horrible that's like
that is
actually horrible that's really it's not
even
like fake letters that make no sense
just flying by like in like
a camera what
look at all this stuff that's not good
you know
remember an alien isolation when it took
you like three hours to
get to even finding an alien
cut down captain keys are you here too
that's what happened after remember
remember after he turned into that big
ball of flood juice he went here
screw you made him out no no you got
caught him come here do i have a second
oh you have you have a shotgun too i'm
gonna use this
go use it to shoot keys then cut him
down and see what he has to say about it
is dropping from the ceiling
with that whoa hey what's up
i love how it makes no noise
i'm bad at these qtes what just tap was
what just happened
um do you see that really massive bug
what the screen just kills zeno
is that his name you gotta kill captain
xeno
oh there it is okay that makes don't
worry about me
go kill that thing no you're it you
gotta kill him
why is his lips not even hardly moving
it's made by fromsoft it was from
software he did it
you know what it's not about i can't
believe that even with all this funding
they still don't have
lips i love the games but that's just
like what you
do they can't even they can hardly even
uh
it was just walking into a wall the
whole time we were running around
that was it it was just walking into a
single wall
you probably walked over it like just
casually stepped on over
and now it's gone are you [ __ ]
serious
they put this out this was a game that
they were allowed to make
oh my god captain keys we gotta go kill
the flute
this is keys from 2-3 sir our mission
was to recover the flight data you mean
3-4-3
you can just walk inside of him we have
to know what caused this
captain keys i just want to get you i
just wanted to get to know you a little
better you mind if i get inside you
you